[Music]
[Applause]
David purdum is uh covering Sports
gambling sports betting industry
reporter and uh joining us now
um recap these gambling allocation
allegations here with Phil Mickelson uh
fact and fiction uh in this it for you
I think there's a lot of fact in there
uh Billy Walters is widely considered
the most successful better ever in
American history as you mentioned he's
extremely well connected and he seems to
have receipts here he had the exact
number of bets that bill made of the two
hundred thousand dollar range exact
number he made of the hundred thousand
dollar range and in total as you
mentioned uh him over the last three
decades Walter believes that Mickelson
got down over a billion dollars in Bets
with a net loss of 100 million the thing
that really stood out to me he said the
only other person that I know that I got
they got that much money down to bet
that much money over that time frame was
his himself so he's basically saying
Phil Mickelson is the second biggest
Sports bettor in the last 30 years in
the U.S
but he could afford it correct correct
100 and Walters acknowledges that too
it's his money uh he never thought that
he would have any trouble collecting if
there was any sort of debts and they had
a partnership where they would uh pay
bets back and forth
um but you know Walters was never
concerned that it made that clear in the
book that uh you know Phil was a better
he had the money to do it and that's
what he chose to do
there's insider trading involved in this
Billy Walters went to prison because of
this uh how much of that is is on Phil
Mickelson of what happened to the author
of this book
well Walters believes that Mickelson
could have testified in his case and
that would have helped him give him a
better chance of staying out of prison
Walters maintains his innocence says he
did not relay any sort of inside
information it was a stock uh trade uh
Dean Dean Foods a dairy company uh Texas
um that they mentioned back and forth uh
Nicholson declined to to testify said he
was going to take the fifth and that red
Walters the the wrong way
and then they sent him to jail and while
he was in jail his daughter committed
suicide and he said you know had he not
been in jail he you know thinks he could
have prevented that but athletes betting
on themselves in golf
uh why should we have a problem with
that boxers are able to bet on
themselves
well there's now a lot of the states
they don't allow anybody that's involved
in a sport to place Wagers on that event
including on themselves and the reason
for that is because let's say an athlete
bets on them to win a golf tournament uh
bets five hundred thousand dollars and
then the next tournament he doesn't bet
well has he is he trying just as hard
this time or maybe the intensity isn't
there so he's not trying his hard so
they think it just kind of impacts the
Integrity a little bit just the efforts
and it adds kind of a question mark
around everything in my opinion it just
kind of opens up a can of worms that's
unnecessary and is a net negative uh on
this if you were to allow athletes to
bet on events that they are involved in
David purdom ESPN sports betting
industry reporter I it feels like we're
headed towards something really bad here
they're just so the it's hard not to bet
it's there it's constant and you're
seeing this with Iowa and Iowa State
athletes involved in this
where are we headed like how do we how
do we police this to ensure that you
don't have something that is going to be
nefarious
well the theory behind the legalization
and the regulation is that what we're
trying to do we have more visibility
into the betting market right now than
we ever had we don't know in the past if
all these transactions were were
happening because it was taking place in
uh you know an underground bookmaker an
underground bookmaker or an offshore
sports book and they don't open up their
books to show you hey this guy's betting
he shouldn't be we're now we're in this
environment of Regulation where more
people are watching uh they can see
these anomalies and we're catching
people uh there's an academic theory
that I kind of like to recite a little
bit it's about adoption and anytime uh
illicit activity like betting is brought
into a regulated environment Society
struggles at the beginning okay what can
I do what can I not do what can I get
away with what what's going to get me in
trouble eventually they adapt right so
it takes about five ten years they start
to learn we start seeing all these cases
people made examples of and Society will
adapt so I hope we're kind of in that
adaptation period but you're right
things are not going well right now
we're seeing way too many kids uh risk
their playing eligibility by betting on
games they're involved in which sport or
sports are most vulnerable
college basketball that's always been
the one that has been a target for Point
shading uh you can control a college
basketball game by just getting one or
two players uh compared to that have
more control compared to a football game
well let me let me ask you then David I
I'm gonna I'm gonna pay I need you to uh
fix a game okay
how do you go about fixing that game
well you'd want to spread the money out
among several Sports books around the
nation probably would like to do it in
one of the offshore Sports books where
you could protect your identity or with
a local bookmaker but how do I find the
players who will be you know complicit
well you go to a college and let's say
hey uh I know you were betting on one of
these sites I don't want to get you in
trouble but maybe we can work out some
sort of deal you know you would shave
some points in this game you miss a
couple free throws here or there and hey
we'll keep it between ourselves uh you
know this happened in the GMAC bowl back
in the mid 2000s with a Toledo running
back he eventually admitted in court
that he fumbled football intentionally
during that game for five hundred
dollars I mean 500 you're a college kid
that's a lot of money that takes your
kids out your girlfriend out for a date
well and that's the thing you got to get
to the most vulnerable and that's what I
always worry about with this but you
know Vegas does a great job policing the
lines when you see some you know you had
the Alabama baseball situation where how
you think that's not gonna you know
raise red flags and I'm sure these Iowa
and Iowa State kids who are betting
probably thinking oh we're at Iowa and
Iowa State they got other things to
worry about you know these are small
bets here and then you find out that
there's there's a lot more to it it's
not necessarily the size of the bed it's
that you're betting and you know that
when it comes to they're gonna take away
your scholarship it's like hey you bet
50 you're betting on your team or
against your team or whatever it might
be it just feels like we're headed down
that road somehow somewhere can you find
a way that NFL players could Gamble
but almost the NFL knows that they would
monitor it they that they would say this
is the only way you can gamble so
there's no gray area there's no nothing
and you just tell them you gamble this
way and we'll let you do that during the
season is there anything that you see
down the road with the NFL players
certainly not betting on anything
related to the NFL players are allowed
to bet on other sports they can bet on
that baseball game or a NBA playoff game
or whatever but they just can't do it
while it works so uh I don't think he
should ever be allowed to bet on
something you were involved with there's
too much information that you have
access to that the other public Bettors
do not there's just too many things that
again I just think it's a net negative
to allow somebody to bet on an event
they're involved in what's your favorite
gambling story whether it's a bad beat
or
you can leave out names but yeah I went
down to Las Vegas a few years ago during
the rodeo and there's these professional
Bettors that are going to go around and
they dress up as Cowboys look like
they're coming out of town and they go
in there and try to dupe the sports
books by letting them to be a lot of
these guys have been cut off by the
sports books they beat them by so so
much they won't let them vet and so we
we drove around and sure enough he would
go up there in this cowboy hat and the
jeans and a big showcase belt buckle and
we'll be allowed to place Wagers that he
would never want so that that's one of
my favorites yeah and we all have a bad
beat uh when I gambled I I tell my
audience it was Packers Bears and I lost
on a blocked field goal that was taken
in for a touchdown Chester Markle was
the field goal kicker and he caught the
deflection and ran it in for a touchdown
he was going to kick field goal I was
going to win
um my bookie had uh the Saints when uh
Tom Dempsey was uh had the the field
goal the longest field goal in NFL
history at the time like you know
everybody has one of those yeah I mean
we we do get those where we win one of
these bets but usually it's a bad beat
that uh you seem to it well it hadn't
left me and it's been uh almost 50 years
so I certainly remember mine 2000
Kentucky Florida College football
Kentucky's favorite excuse me Florida's
favorite Steve Spurrier Kentucky's
covering the game the whole way I think
there's getting plus seven or something
Florida's down to the last Drive late in
the fourth quarter up for Kentucky sure
they're just gonna kneel down right yeah
nope Warrior goes play action touchdown
covers the spread with like two seconds
left or something was crazy
if you ran into Spurrier would you say
anything to him well he talked about it
afterwards the game saying well they
were blitziness they were blitzing us
still so we had to take advantage of
that so yeah I might bring that up good
to talk to you David thank you for
joining us again that's David pertem
ESPN sports betting industry reporter